[Music]
what up what up y'all
what of y'all how's it going happy
Tuesday Tuesday 2nd day of the week well
kind of
again our girl we're getting our grind
going it's only Tuesday we got it though
exactly exactly what we're doing oh I'm
doing great how are you Richard
doing great thank you how are you yes
first year joined by Richie we're
playing some plants vs. zombies battle
for neighbor Ville this is actually not
out yet completely it comes out October
18 but for those of you who have
purchased the founders Edition you
actually have access for this game six
weeks early so it's even been out for a
few weeks even prior to this moment so
that's pretty awesome
obviously stuff like this is used to
help enhance gameplay and everything for
final release personally though if I'm
being honest all the plants vs. zombies
games I've played have not been the
shooter ones they've been the ones we
actually like plan your plans Ami's
black bar bill stuff and so now this is
my first chance actually playing like
the shooter version which is pretty
interesting so far I haven't done much I
had just started it up and I did my
little introductory quests here with a
major sweetie a beautiful sunflower with
an eye patch
they do have giddy Park down here which
is kind of like the training grounds I
guess before you go into a cult whoa I
just meant to preview it no mere deer
now down into the action and so
obviously you can choose the plant side
or the zombie side and then there's a
bunch of different characters for each
side it's pretty interesting it's game
looks very nice what up jack hey
everyone is going Bob Jones Bob Jones
and crying our returning faces so these
are just like randoms computers but some
other players you come in here sometimes
but yeah I'm gonna walk home real quick
all these robots beat me up enough of
that and show a little bit of the kind
of open area ish you can buy rewards
which can be like cosmetic upgrades and
stuff like that gotta have you level up
I think I'm like level 5 or level 4 like
that and then you have these three
abilities of each
which do different types of dubia pretty
cool and then this one like he jumps in
the air tackles out I've only played two
multiplayer matches so far but it kinda
seems like the zombies are cheaper than
planned but I can't make any actual
sound decisions on that just yet yeah
we'll see here in a bit the other
characters I was using
minja but here's where I was saying this
is kind of like very over watching in my
opinion so we have like our attack
characters who all have their
personalities to Chomper Colonel Korn
and you got defense characters oh nice
there's our tank acorn think it's like
this Groot like trees support so like I
said I have only just really started
playing a little bit ago got through the
tutorial stuff so we can kind of all
check this out together there is a
sprint this is like left stick yeah like
this is how he look [ __ ] and he's
walking we're at running plant it's kind
of scary if a plant was running at me
like that
poor zombie um nightcap though his red
animation is adorable it's all squeaky I
would not be scared let me throw no
volume I love it so you could really
hear the squeak love it yeah it's
awesome such a wholesome little
character
Joel's like override you plants vs.
zombies Percy now yes yes no but for
people who haven't played this game that
might be one easiest thing to compare it
to you know yeah someone in the chat
said the corn is good to play let's see
what some of his ability reveal enemy is
nice
hassey cold butter leap over enemies
while launching a volley of explosive
kernels downwards and launch to highly
explosive cubs I like that yeah watch
out for those cause that's like the
matrix
[Music]
pretty intense cooldowns all right there
so let's go let's go battle it out I'm
ready to get it yes let's go I just
jumped through expecting it goes to my
so there's different playlists you can
say turf takeover 24 player battles like
what do you figure it's aureus I think
this is like team deathmatch gym bang no
no it's like a Dave I think it's better
the death match honestly all of the
descriptions and game-like modes and
stuff like that sounds super hardcore
and even when you're talking the major
sweetie at the beginning in the tutorial
quests they're all adorable and they're
like yeah my favorite things explosion
like mix modes a mix of no bomb suburban
nation vanquish confirmed vanquish
convert have so many different playlists
already this is great
yeah garden warfare 2 was the one before
this and I always just enjoyed like the
play on words yeah we can see where they
took inspiration from so I'm sure
anybody who's played the garden warfare
versions of this game probably know all
about this for sure you know let's just
try some straight-up team
let's do it well yeah oh yeah oh good
nice here we go I was waiting for it to
jump through and get to this we had to
set it up first that's all
Joel says gw2 was so fun dude what was
your favorite parts about garden warfare
DOS crime is here yeah oh yeah all right
all I'm on Team zombies this time Oh
interesting
okay so I'm gonna try to make it through
a bunch of different characters just
because this is the character in our
thumbnail oh yeah I'll be first are
those roller skates with like yeah with
like rocket boosters what great control
look at that straight all right no so
thoughtful like the whoa I would have
done like busting my butt already okay
so let's see got some electric bolts
already really see em you're right how
can you be mad at that though are we
gonna try the campaign montar respond I
mean I am down for that
we're just taking a gander at the
multiplayer real quick I actually want
to see what some of my abilities feels
so I did my nice dog I should have read
these things before I hand will see what
mine looks like your team's doing good
though they're helping out too you got
him oh oh wow that really did not look
like it looked like that was a cutscene
after we won it it's like you lost sorry
we joined a game that was already almost
over Wow
now they get to flex on us a little bit
here talk Vanquisher 18 vanquishes Wow
how did we lose well I was definitely
negative one I joined and I died once
you contributed though those two guys
there you go are you owing some point
you earn some points actually get into a
match from the beginning let's go play
Gaiden opps please okay I'm gonna do
this round and then we'll go back and
check it out we got you I just wanna I
want to check out these characters all
right we're on team plants this time
okay so I think the little numbers on
the top is kind of how many other people
on our team am I using that character
okay so for sure we have one sunflower
[Music]
you know what let's try mr. corn on the
cob
yeah first of 50 so moving the chat
center earlier right now I'm looking at
it buddy I was do little corn cob but
she he does I love all their their run
cycles this game is graphically an
impressive yeah it's so nice there they
go Sarah swarming okay so I can reveal
people and he can use your abilities
running around with those nice
oh no oh my corncob yeah okay okay oh
yeah they're running away we got them on
the run so close the corn guy is great
because it was like a little machine gun
he does I love the sound effect you
think yeah I don't even want it like
ruin my impression I thought about it
well there's that flow that's cool bye
miss that's alright you still look so
cool doing you regenerate how dare you
how's the rest of our team doing oh you
did oh yeah that was fun
great okay I got to remember my LV is
like where um right right little Ren
that was dope
he got behind like the tombstone the
grave is not free and if you purchase
founders addiction which is given we
have then you have access to it early oh
no oh no super zombie I see why that
real yeah I know that's okay I see why
that thing has such a long cooldown
because it's pretty good yeah it's worth
it you knocked that super zombie out oh
that might be revived my teammates are
oh oh they're too busy though yes there
you go fine run my little corns back
over there I think we can play co-op but
we have one code so we're going yeah we
only have one copy of a game right now
that's her she's got this on lock though
yeah I think some split screen action
would be fun although I do love me some
co-op and split screen game there we go
here's the fight nice they're running
away
oh you got a little bit you got a little
bit it's a tie game right now
14 first offense is gonna take forever
how do we jump into a game so late last
it was ice here we go whoa
that flip Oh bonus points oh and you
avenge them my fellow Correns where's
the action I know there you go we
Colonels stick together co-op can meet
split-screen but something like we but
also rip alright whoa that guy's got
like a cannon we've seen enough of corn
man let's let's check out some of the oh
sure
shadow night cap is so adorably we have
to yeah yeah
tweak my way of use a little stink
stream hey let's see
where the party at my little ninja stars
and then my ability is really good Wow
whoa
and yes like a little race thing you do
have like a little portal run I know
where's the other half of that guy my
heart is beating this would be a cool
game for the Nintendo switch you know if
it's coming to the switch version or
it's a difficulty I would hope so
all I do know is that this is a PC
version it might look like it's the next
box written cuz I'm playing with a
controller that gun is powerful it's
fine it's fine
it isn't a reader right huh his arms are
so small I barely even noticed but
you're right I wish I could use my
little is it just loading up oh there we
go it's a close game 34 to 33 we're
winning though by one point two points
now why can't I use my LB it's totally
ready
Kevon oh the sound effects are very few
just adorable Wow whoa
you're dangerous a little mushroom dare
he do this oh she's such an adorable
little fun guy oh I was he reviving his
friend I think so maybe I can use my
[Laughter]
there we go oh whoa wipe that guy out
I'm in the forest field I am a level
five I've gained a thousand coins yeah
Jim
we juked him ten away trophies made for
tacos y'all
that's what fixes a message just said
okay yeah that zombie is buff he's a
super zombie we learned and just like
knocked us all out Oh me
they're targeting oh he did run rats
there you go you still when you're still
picking at him though you got him okay
assist my little ninja stars oh yeah
destroyed
man I like this game a lot I like more
than I really did Oh No whoa hey you
were our numbers though maybe I didn't
see the score it sounds like a victory
song to me
yeah yeah I at least got like to go
there do the team-up thing with some
nuts
oh yeah like his little tree trunk I
think like character like members of the
team can join it Oh three players that
was fun let's go talk I mean let's go
try this other mode you guys were
telling us about
yeah good game y'all GG you buy with
coins you know like it's just cosmetic
stuff you can buy stuff from the reward
shop and there are other things like
there's a bunch of little places sweep
inside a little open world area that you
can buy stuff from I've only tried the
was God reward a Tron or something like
that yeah yeah what's happening here pop
cat we want to try some garden a pumpkin
which is loading image like the little
sunflower yeah the Lord reminds me of
the Yoshi's Island uh-huh the health bar
ooh we got a pro tip you can sear the
jetpack ability with the corn character
so instead of just like a doing it
can you play split-screen on PC I
haven't seen the option for that but
that would be awesome
yeah yeah you can get packs and like
upgrades I think possibly fire creeper
in the chat what up and for anybody who
does have the founders edition there is
already like a six week roadmap or
something like that what is happening
here am I about to reset is that what's
happening oh no I'm too impatient for
things like this all right I'm gonna
reset this hi guys hello how's it goin
what's up y'all well someone has earlier
and soon yeah
refreshing in here someone asked earlier
like what happened to all the music I
thought there was these games have like
really good music um I didn't hear any
during battle except for when we won I
wonder oh right um yeah I guess I wasn't
really paying attention to that you were
in the middle of that yeah like let's go
alright sorry about that guys yeah Joel
says PopCap servers r.i.p a little bit
yeah there was a wall there oh snap
crime
crime laying out the pot tanks he said
I'm just gonna say it no matter how
beautiful frostbite is it's the worst
game engine out
ouch ouch ouch hot hey they're trying
that's why they're they're working on
this stuff giving us early access see
where they can improve yeah always room
for improvement
alright let's get back to the action
Jonas agrees Jonas to remember that it's
still early access yes oh yes sir the
theme says oh wait what's the difference
from the previous game our plants vs.
zombies professional Joel in the chat
should definitely so this guy gives you
stuff - oh dang Dave bubbles so you can
go there and get free stuff and sign
them alright Garden ops why is it stop
loggin just shoot some zombies ready
alright so garden ops here we go let's
do it let's do mortal open I actually
love the little part Elaine just jump in
yeah I think this was the map from
earlier the z-tech Factory it was a
really nice map
the eight nerd says you should be able
to split screen hold square X and a
lobby before you go into a gamer mission
oh okay we'll try it out and then maybe
I mean I if they'll let us do a co-op I
could play on PC and give you the
controller if you want oh for sure HS it
might reach it reaches oh yeah okay
we'll try that after this oh man well
Joel you're professional here because
you're giving us all the the wiki facts
and Snapple facts we need the pro tips
and the pro tips so we appreciate that
like so many games out there it's hard
to know everything or I've tried
everything or a plate everything but
that's why we like streaming it and
playing it with you guys in chat cuz
then you guys know all the good stuff
yeah we got the code this morning we're
happy to try it out yeah sort of learned
together here what genre of game is this
gonna be so this is pretty much like a
third-person shooter yeah cartoony it
takes a lot of inspiration at least in
the naming conventions and gameplay
styles from like Call of Duty
battlefield and the names that were
pretty funny what was it a vanquish I
forgot the mode yes he maintained bank
wish oh man come on
quit with the tees and let us put yeah
we had a few good games going I guess
there's probably not that many people in
their servers right now although well
that might be it that's my guess oh nice
Jonas says I also have played all the
pvz games whoa nice very nice very nice
yeah like I really enjoyed you know the
original version which was you know you
just plant the plants you wait so you
accumulate all the Sun you need to plant
another plant and stuff like that yeah
we go I like tedious like farming games
like that
so I really enjoyed that but never had
the chance to play the shooter version
which you know thinking about it now
especially with pulling last few matches
I'm like why didn't I sure yeah earlier
that game that you described earlier we
were just kind of waiting and planning
things that's all I knew this game to be
so it's pretty awesome like I've always
seen it but never had chance try it so
that's pretty dope
yikes this game would do so well on
switch I guess that's what I said - yeah
I agree Spence
boy breathing boy well thanks for
hanging in there guys I'm gonna see if
we get to the bottom of this I mean
earlier when I joined the match it did
take a little while for the game to
actually start but we might be stuck
maybe I'm not sure we were getting stuck
earlier when we were leaving the lobby
yeah
sammy asks why it's taking so long we
think cuz it's a it's an early access
still that's our best guess we had a few
good matches in we're just look like
it's more I'm sad because everyone in
the chat was like you have like right
now it's trigarta Knox and I really
wanted to try it and it's whomp whomp
okay you know I'm gonna feel real bad if
I go to restart this and the second idea
it actually comes back will be okay
let's refresh one more game
sorry guys yeah thanks again for hanging
in there we want to believe just as that
yeah that we want to hang around I
promise it's getting me anxious now
probably says F yeah a little left there
well loading F all right
we're connecting again it's all good
Joel tell me something about your day to
kill the mood
well well loading screen movie screens
all morning and a little bit of editing
then lunch later how about you I
actually got tasked with an amazing job
today which was to place in Final
Fantasy 7 one time very much like a bar
exam right all right so oh man my wack
backwards walk is so slow I just wanted
to see hold X I'm holding X see we just
switched split-screen might have to get
a second controller and controller to
activate that which is all good team
load that players work together defeat
waves of noise noise alright first we're
gonna pray to the gods that this portal
takes us to where we need to go here
portal gods to the right place to where
we need to go slow walk to our feet
finding the best Oh Mario
hey what up okay he says I will up the
content what we love that you love our
content thanks for tuning in that's for
all of you thank you
Manuel is the perfect like oh here we go
ready flanker in the chat what up all
right we're on team zombies gasp family
dinner air explosive rocket hold enemies
and location powerful mech spin and fire
blasters that's not fun super brains is
there's the buff samba4 with the great
hair yeah you pick you know what let's
try this
just tell me very next wave begins Easy
Rider second all right so we're battling
the plants is what I'm assuming install
agree of o matic
is that what's in your hand I think
that's just my gun
oh yeah it it it's like a crossbow well
it looks like one pepper just like
waiting here
I know wait wait one oh here they come
get up oh okay I can charge it up for a
more intense shot
whoa that's awesome and we have to wait
18 seconds that's all right it's only
wave one yeah we won easy think this is
where we tell what for ending the grab o
matic right defending it okay cool
you know when you play a lot of like cod
zombies where I like your sword what do
you think of court move your legs this
is the most adorable adorable I hear the
music now - oh no they're getting to it
the grave automatic that zombie the
super zombie oh no but it's nice because
they're not like bullets it's just like
you know some like purple laser thing
but we have to defend our rate-o-matic
now these plants they don't know what
they're up against um Joel says wait
this is not garden table so it might be
a mix between this and a couple of other
ones like a playlist oh there we go
is so funny
[Music]
Kaspar says this is a new Hawkeye you
got that bow zombie okay
only five more enemies left
[Music]
there we go yeah I love that uppercut
from that other guy the super breeze
yeah
[Music]
there we go but look at that damage I
right I'll need to use this on him but I
would that's three more three more bad
guys super bad guys
[Music]
oh it's gonna help us out one more
zombie I mean the plant where is he
going where is he is that him who they
got him I'm just shooting through nice
wait one complete yeah this game sound
is so cute it is overall this whole game
is just adorable but the sound helps
with that for sure I like the character
design too and the level design it's
also approachable and friendly yes I
like Irene so wave 2 is now beginning I
wonder if I could change my character in
between rounds maybe every other round
I'll change my character I'm assuming
vaccination points are where they're
coming
yep there they come yeah you got one D
no now these ones look angry they have
their little their eyebrows are like are
now Oh level to you
nice roll nice roll yeah without
charging up getting some help though
that looks like oh it's so funny it's
like you're barely covering any ground
but you're running like a thousand miles
per hours oh no these plants these
enemies are getting bigger grief o matic
is safe
oh right that's all we need to defend so
far it's a get away from our grief
we were too busy like they snuck up on
us
[Music]
we got yep that unlock about half way
through here the early access is now for
those who have the founders Edition the
game releases October 18 for everybody
oh man she's shipping away here hell
yeah okay it looks like it stopped so
that's like an escape a little bit but
push you forward it makes a bomb B thank
you
yeah they're attacking the grave of
addict
don't wait you little pumpkin head
hitting uppercut yeah body
I wonder how intense the skits it's both
pretty chillax right yeah it is only
wave to by predict this is gonna be like
this to damage what god of them
hey hey
guy
like a champ though sunflower over there
no we're talking trash oh oh oh oh
thanks nice all right they're done are
you let's see can I don't see even maybe
not in this mode we're stuck with him
pro tip if you try to plant as that
character then the RV power will do more
damage right bumper ok so thanks combo
gotcha here we go
wave three
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay
oh no you're so far for the grave of
that it they feel like I don't even run
that fast and all I'm gonna say by the
grave Oh Maddie yeah well right back
percent and there's superbrain yeah
alright here we go
that little robots helping out gottoms
night
[Music]
I'll stay kind of close right
oh let me the puppy filled that box here
we go support mail a little please some
range action
sweet I think adoption that's so helpful
Wow kind of a quiet start I feel like
they're about to rush us all
there's one little Pumpkinhead good run
is new so scram interesting
I like the big add a new mechanic and
still give it like so much personality
oh that's all right he's getting
uppercutted right now nice oh yeah
he did
[Music]
Jewell says they really went overboard
with the run animations aside every game
is getting even more crazy if you didn't
see earlier but we had the other
character who's on rollerblades I just
realized I'm missing a shoe you want
more here we go here's where the action
yeah we had to rollerblade on I think
that was a good time
[Music]
nice okay so if I do a backward then I
throw the little TMC in front these are
new enemies yeah they have vases on
their head yeah they have pots on their
heads I do
but beans on my head but don't call me a
bean head or whatever yeah peas on my
head yeah I do
[Laughter]
never thought of that a long time I
[Music]
complete all right the grave Ematic
isn't good health oriented is in the
back thumbs when Sarah a success up we
stop robots you all right
there were toys that I felt like you
guys wiped them out faster though I have
to respawn in the pause menu oh do I
have to die
I might have to die Oh No so change my
character whoa these are much bigger now
[Music]
there we go this sounds all intimidating
my turn is up there's like five that was
a good hit done oh the charge up sign
for that gun it's something serious
there's one they're not getting to the
grave nomadic which is good we're still
at 92% help Oh again to you though I
know well there it is
it's night oh you got him
Joel such violence plant violence oh
they're here they're getting closer
but then you walk back that role Wow
yeah they're getting close
you got the cell we're all here that's
uneven we're nowhere near the end of the
way over now
oh no it's stinking
[Music]
oh man they're home they're ganging up
oh okay
[Music]
Jonas thinks that in between rounds
we'll be able to respond as a new
character possible okay yeah
whoa nice move
[Music]
get away from it our grave o matic
rude plans I like that character it's
like a construction worker zombie all
right we're clear now only four left
y'all
Oh
oh nice
oh yeah let's run over there and then
was that Ave later it's like these last
few are putting up a fight okay can I
change my character now no no option
here did we all dies that are great wait
oh no I don't like this
did we man status y'all know where was
that like eighty percent I think cuz
everyone's dead
yikes oh well that's good to know about
the five rounds I thought it would keep
going yeah great effort though I think
super brains had like a hundred bang
finishes over there and now you can play
with someone else well if you want to
keep going with this mode I think what
mode does chat want to see who was there
was something else right oh I forgot
what it was called whatever a little bit
of everything for y'all f you got
planted oh yeah
alright were plants this time for sure
let's see I kind of really like I was
like the corn guy
it's buildin turf takeover
whoa okay I think is this guidance when
it started it said ops over on the left
so maybe they mixed both versions into
one playlist that sounds likely for
early access so after this we'll try
some of the other modes because there's
like four other multiplayer modes in
here including to take over and the
mixed modes I want to try to see where
the campaign of that - yeah for sure
I can't think of uh I mean uh I can't
campaign mode for this this seems so
like base they'd be fun to play campaign
MOBA like this might be why shine
well test Somme B's they're crazy d-day
was up there it was spittin facts
boneheads see who's an enemy oh that's
fun it's like a leave spin your little
character reminds me of the ones from
Kingdom Hearts of bad guys let's no
fungus ones that don't hurt you but you
have to cast magic on them got him there
he is is the TV on his head I love that
little fungus guy though he only has
like 75 holes he does I just notice that
it's a lot lower than a Easy Rider guy
from earlier but his attack is stronger
yeah yeah there it is
[Laughter]
TV head get away oh yeah they're too
close
[Applause]
only four left I like this map I like
this temple yeah Tomb Raider honor yeah
[Music]
oh stop it grandma one left one left
yeah wait oh no that's weird treats
Richard plans around oh wait one
complete no knockout bonus okay so wait
there's only five rounds round so we can
get through five rounds you came close
lesson
what is that tethering you friend Eli
gave me some shield
oh I now have a hundred home oh cool
yeah sunflower is a support that's great
I even saw the buses like
what's-her-name over watch when she do
you mercy here they come whoa that was
cool
[Music]
I'm adding her own Oh conehead
oh it's a hat I thought it was like a
traffic cone my little fungus ninja
stars I'm waiting for there to be like a
big group so I can use my super like
liability yeah you gotta save that there
we go that's such that's great ninja
move Master Yi actions that cue there
you go
yay thank you sunflower I know
make me a strong little fungi I came
over here to kill that guy but
hear that little giggle Tokyo
can't reach me too slow Oh
jerks there we go
like one guy there that's right worth it
that's always worth it
[Music]
like how much health a coin has in
comparison to me and with top left or
Topher's oh wow yeah definitely the tank
only three left doll said join the big
tree oh okay okay okay let me see in the
sand with see that's our tank friend oh
I think I have to be an acorn also
actually okay if I can change next round
I will
I don't know this one's heavily armed
whoa in case him in the steam yeah he
was a foot soldier no you get to learn
their names that way all right here we
go wait three this is what did it for us
last time we got this yeah no worries
Jonas we're gonna play all the modes
today at least a few times we still have
plenty of time on stream as well so
thank you all for joining yeah how's
everyone doing in chat
we'll get Ritchie in on a few games here
and once we finish this so he can give
it a whirl I don't know I think you got
it down but I mean I mean they want to
see me with you play cause it's pretty
much all the buttons are the same
grenades melee there you go here they
come miss Biggs leveling up I think I
might low-key it's so cute they're just
hanging around like a shooter in with
maximum cuteness I'm pretty sure this is
everything I need and our gardener is at
100% television I know here we go for
support with my strafing oh you got
super zombies in
nice you know surprisingly my ninja
stars do a lot of damage but your was I
just like really handicapped with
homeboy Hawkeye last round baby but
those are those little ones you're
throwing and they're limited they kind
of end quickly huh yes I have to
yeah you might be super breezy on the
fifth round there will be a surprise
oh you know what we gotta make it this
round now chad is telling up they gave
it chat is telling us that it's a boss
wave or are you up for it I am ready
me and my fungi are ready oh yeah Pedro
I need this on the switch I thought it'd
be perfect for the switch you know but
uh I'm not sure if there's any sign of
it just yet I got the fling Hey you get
away with more friends you were great
last time around this time we had like
80% health on the garden ater or
whatever was called before
I also think it's a nice map for like
having a advantage up top like that just
now yeah
okay tell you a bit about which
direction they're gonna be coming from
I love that the music is getting this
music is good the characters are really
fun and it's like kind of so far it's
been pretty nice easy pick-up-and-play
voted so fast okay we got it on lock
okay thank you
only one zombie left
[Music]
[Music]
oh no we're yet
[Music]
hmm where's this last guy I know I feel
like he's glitched out in the corner
somewhere I'll find it probably if there
was a cone head zombie earlier though we
go like rescue him and exercise
time for wave 4 fully healed all right
he does when you say surrett here we go
some more support plants which kind
special wave Robo boogie that's what
it's called get ready
oh oh okay okay got it
TVN
no they okay good keep there all the way
collecting the garden later can't have
them here the coordinator look how they
changed up the music to make it seem
more boss battling hey hey watch it you
respect your fungi hair I think those
are my favorite enemy the TV's on you
would think they'd be pretty strong
there's one nice it's like always just
like one straggler whoa there he is
I like that zombie
I was pulling man
so far doing good got a lot of support
from these little plants and our tomato
they like gonna go where they are
there's one oh it's already dead see
whoa
I'm eyes expecting to turn that corner
and like see a bunch of zombies there
but what I get we haven't tried out
split-screen yet but uh we we don't want
to stop at the cost of that like we
might just continue to take turns or I
think I might go next but someone was
feeling you I think oh only three left
you guys got this then you can make it -
wait whoa
got him all right
[Music]
nice corner them I love crazy to you
he looks pretty funny in this little
like 3d ish mode and so the 2d voters
dude we're in good shape y'all ha ha how
can I donate no need to donate bro
you're donating your time to us so
that's actually more than enough bro
whoa alright boss defeat bonus here's
the line and then after this I'm excited
to see some of the other playlists too
so let's see if we can get through this
I feel like whoa okay
oh my god all right
perfect we can get him close to that
dark nadir wrong
oh no [ __ ] head where's the team there
you go
okay all this music it's on now
hey yo there you go it's pretty awesome
because they still include all the
versions of the zombies that they had
like in the old school game very good no
one's at the garden a derp
right yeah look uh
oh that was gonna hey I like this
when it's just chaotic the whole time
this is great
Oh No
oh nice your shield blocked his attack
oh hey hey yeah you can shoot through
felt like they can that's really cool in
my views I'm poison damage
oh there we go
about halfway through
[Music]
my leader in the hub there's a boss and
someone to talk to
Oh Sophie I think in that main hub area
we can speak to the right person and
start the story mode good looking out
Jonas yeah you got this only five bad
guys left hopefully they're not massive
I think I spoke too soon
the music came they did he's running
away I know you're scared now there's
only four baddies left I'm like do we
wanna register because the garden is
over here you know bye Missy wait ninja
stars hey Jim
yes oh he's almost done he's running
away oh my god no he's baiting us so
hard no one else has helped me the last
four characters will be bosses like this
I'm feeling Oh
whoa
we're all on him though he's less than
half help you guys
[Music]
the big
yeah okay you ready for the next one yep
it's totally all bosses now from here on
out I think we got Ono the garden yeah
this is bad this is that ITV's actually
got body over here perfect
oh yeah we sell our friends all right
our teammates are back that's great they
were dead
man they came out of nowhere we were so
far away being baited by those other
boss no getting baited I knew it - I
knew it magician guy Wow it's like he's
the last guy though now he's going away
okay eunuch completed hands are sweaty
I'll give you a high all right yes now
[Music]
our team with that was tough towards the
end there there is so thank you yeah but
that was fun I liked that all right so
many boys kitty part and then somebody
told us about how to get to this
campaign yeah it looks like speaking to
the right person in the hub area we'll
get it started on that I was boss so do
we want to see any more multiplayer
modes or do we just want to spend the
last 25 minutes or so in campaign but
these are the decisions I mean we did
play like a game and a half of vanquish
we played the garden and graveyard ops
yeah the mixed modes we didn't try and I
don't think we tried turf takeover on
stream although I did play like half the
game before this your game but I kind of
feel like some sort of getting down to
the last like 25 minutes of stream maybe
campaign yeah I'm gonna sure if I saw
one but we haven't explored too much
yeah the main hub there's a lot go to
the great night yeah pretty much
man when I went to either they had that
giant like van and everything there oh
they did yeah that's funny the bus
squeaks of your feet I know I love it
that's probably the reason why here we
go that was a little lay out there Wow
travels a sound sensor oh yeah I think I
had to meet major sweetie there
at some point teams which is your combat
by rare item knowing holy Toledo
the bus area there is a plant to talk to
what's bounced deep yeah turf takeover
that's a new garden warfare nice yeah
well let Ritchie play story mode once I
find that what do I have to go to town
center oh is this the Buster a little
rundown RV oh yeah your turn Ritchie
alright we'll go easy on me y'all I
don't play this yeah look at that hair
Vivian oh no so upset okay so let's go
save save neighbor ville yeah I can't
let these zombies take over the hood
alright not how this works
whoa Cosmetics
I think the Rose is so awesome
and the roof is like a support character
which makes total sense launch y'all
ready launch - drop hills in town center
okay there we go
you're on the way let us pray we get
past this yeah where your hands and chat
please
sweet
I'm really impressed with you know they
might call Dave crazy but he's out here
with a flying them and we're not so just
getting my buttons down yeah well okay
there's that shield school all right
yeah there's this special oh no wait
what did that one do was that the Wraith
run yeah okay
all right so I'm gonna follow this
exclamation point business y'all go
Vaughn oh right he's like woo pvz theme
music good little three seconds of it
all you need those don't mind me just
catch him a breath sergeant peel in the
flash is freaking epic mind if I call
you sprout okay why don't you help my
squad with their seriously tough mission
I think we're ready y'all yeah so many
people are talking about tacos it is
good day after all
oh that's perfect unos dos Li first
mission convert tacos let's go well
that's nothing my first mission I need
tacos backing up okay
maybe next time sprouts okay I goof yeah
I got baited to a raw deal what is this
now yeah the iPad touches see the
sunflower seed attention to detail
exactly it sure is great and all over
like fingers are like medals of honor
oh they are begin quest here we go be
okay from now on we're gonna call
Ritchie sprout I like it
I'm down that's what a grandpa called
Tommy and Rugrats sprout every time
you're on stream now instead of Richie
on the intro
yeah let's adjust it to say sprout need
your help save us all okay these appear
to be side missions I see well did we
goof again oh well let's see what we can
do here you know me sprout peaceful here
nope there's a treasure chest in there
in the hot tub
oh wow good eye oh now can I work for
that Colonel guy I have 20 tacos they're
just out here
you know that she said I went to the
wrong side of the neighborhood over here
retry she was upset you're on your lawn
yeah I guess what lawn but yeah I'm on
her sand rib okay go to the old cool
executive club this game really respects
the roots of the franchise does it can
you speak to that you played more of
these than me no I'm I'm out here again
just trying to get to the other side of
town the cod is the intuition I'm gonna
flank him flank nope there's more over
here
throw your bubble shield on them I think
if they're in it they take like damage
over time free tacos oh yeah I don't
know if I want them from the zombies
pocket yeah yes I took them anyway how
well there we go I'm dressed
we got you bros dancing cactus
you can't stop dancing it's up to me
okay Brad you believe there we go all
right I'm not trapped excellent we do
Dulce it's the case throughout the whole
chats got you back
appreciate y'all firstly though you laid
the groundwork got this here we go
oh no he's trying to get my next
objective here gotta save our other our
fellow plants yep oh no I hope that's
cool
here you take that side I'll take this
side got him
you take the crazy scientist lady great
movie meet Sheldon Oh
throw your bubble on a pail v Toby oh
yeah too far we good Lord no no special
talent how'd you do that cool special R
you like jump on the walls just run in
there and press why why okay another one
you got you rescue him yeah those from
the cactus yes recruiting my team yes
all right I think there's more I need
saving over here - oh yeah yeah they're
markers what platform is this releasing
for well we're playing currently on PC
right now um actually I should sure you
want to swap seats alright since you
guys did have a lot of questions about
this earlier
I was playing so shouldn't get you the
deets
here we go now we're underground here
exclusive club okay we made it to the
club y'all yeah turning up on Tuesday
[Music]
yeah
oh look I'm Way too and cool and way to
unzoom B apparently yeah can i it does
nothing I need a disguise or something
Oh major sweetie things are cool and
myself and all of chat thanks here calls
sprout all right well she says go back
to the base and we think of a new plan
there now that I got my squad we can
rethink this let's go oh when I got
three tacos from that box No
okay yeah so PC Xbox one PlayStation 4
that is available on
if you've ordered the founders Edition
which is the Edition we're playing right
now you get early access yeah six weeks
early access because the full game
doesn't drop until October HP with it a
long time but no single week from now
until launch they're releasing on your
new like more new things modes playlists
rewards that's cool if you guys are at
all interested I recommend it I'm
already having fun
I know Persia had fun too I know so like
I just start playing it we just got the
code today and I was like oh this should
be fun but it was way more fun than I
expected it to be so I'm excited
the demon when you kill someone is so
chatted it frees Emily let's go little
lawnmower I have to escort this
lawnmower like that's all tiny like yeah
I'll leave I'll cover you
Anthony says six weeks of early access
that is I know that's not love their
fans I guess oh here we go oh yeah oh
yeah look they're burning in their your
bubble oh no that's also a very Naruto
move yes my team Osborne's helping out
man chat is killing it with the funds
today Grim Reaper says you have to play
for ethically it was my cat you know I'm
okay with this all the coins man I'm
just trying to export my friend yeah a
little on over here the payload yeah
this is a mini payload mission come on
oh he's going the other way he said that
we're trying to help you will man what's
today's founder rewards it is um well
week three is founder reward let me save
this long board hey bubble victory slab
reward
[Music]
said nice on you proud you're a blooming
world oh so happy to have you here no no
sorry I think I accidentally mute your
mouth well either way it's fine now
right in order to collect all of the
weekly rewards you have to log in during
that week and if you miss that week then
you can't redeem it
so that's their way of encouraging you
to stay on police this londo so funny
I'm glad it doesn't take damage or
anything yeah it's being controlled wait
for me okay this is home base I think
yeah the lawnmower is back we did y'all
anything about it plants being friends
with a lawnmower sounds like an oxymoron
why the zombies liked it so much we did
it you guys can follow Ritchie on
Twitter I am there I haven't changed my
name to sprout on Twitter yet but it's
I'm gonna pull up this damn Jesse you
guys can get his change this to say
sprout yeah oops wrong button there we
go Operation makeover you want to give
these mini missions a try that is all
you isolated for the first half and
you've got it okey doke other versions
of this game also adorable seeing how
they kind of converted it over to a
shooter aspect it's cool like I said
earlier they really they know their fan
base and how did he put it like they
respect their fan base in this regard
you got moves sprout yeah now I have
tacos - taco giving moves of course yeah
why can't I be named taco in service bro
oh well exchange tacos for coin oh do I
need coins at the moment I mean I just
wanted to see oops don't let those burn
a hole in your pocket all right how many
Queens do I have we've got yeah I don't
think I need to exchange for coins at
the moment but wait did he offer any
more missions or just like currency
exchange he might be a store okay I
think that's what's going on or
something of the sort a map no we can be
[Music]
Joel said you're not off the hook yet
sprout we still need you oh I'm here hi
I see you later
Abner thanks for tuning in eh yeah bye
catch next time every weekday 11 a.m. we
go lies oh no a little turf war out here
is rude friendlies okay let's see I'm
trying to find a automation point over
here right there oh there we go
that's always looking for it there's a
few now all right that just sounds like
ways of use yeah there we go
oh this is how we get cool and by
helping people out see I like the
message in this yeah be cool it's not
like robots like you're not cool enough
and instead of being like you know up
those social media followers yeah be
cool get out there and help your
community
exactly all right let's get some cool
points oh man something really cool like
a wine trip oh man I need all three of
these things
oh she just said that okay you need to
get it that hat off of his head not this
guy but here we go
I have no friends at the moment again
oh no sprout is alone go to the sewers
here we go we go live every weekday at
11 a.m. that is our time we play various
games we play games at our new games we
get early access to games that may be
out already but get new updates or
sometimes a new game will get announced
at is maybe like a part of a series and
we get to go back and play older
versions of their games so oh that trash
we do play a little bit of everything go
version holding it down here every
weekday come on back stop by watch us
again 11 a.m. Pacific Standard Time that
is correct
cron thank you time to put my skills to
the test
I need that hat lecture I need to be
cool yeah whoa whoa finessed
[Music]
yikes whoa
okay stun domain D nope oh yeah I forgot
I have a cooked an upgrade onto this
character that the more enemies you kill
the faster health regenerate so I guess
one needs you know let's come perfect
question you do a little combo so you're
getting the health factory direct were
you going so that's something else cool
and this game that I actually didn't
show very much but should have you could
upgrade your characters with like skill
points and ability points which we
probably have a lot of right now yeah
we've been getting some coins - oh dear
oh I can't look oh I'm stuck in
okay you I'm feeling better already I
can't see okay there we go
wait these bats are all in my face crime
is asking do I know what Ben and John
Luke are gonna do for Friday since they
miss last week I'm not sure I know they
wanted to do Gears multiplayer last week
they were both super busy in the office
so they could do it I don't know if
they're going to run that anyways or
possibly play the cod beta cuz the
ground war mode is gonna be available
starting this weekend I believe so might
be a good chance for them to fill the
lobby with a bunch of the child watching
yours and then go you know fight against
the world double D I'm so excited for
ground war this is a ground war right
now I know
at the defendants for four more seconds
sprout comes up but yeah you guys we are
live every weekday 11 a.m. Pacific time
and on Fridays we have community Fridays
so that's when Ben and John Luke
actually step in instead of myself and
play community games but inside in for
brain guys too so we've got all the
action going on here
gamespot live oh yeah snoop around for
some clues good guy you sing you down
there and he's like uh this is him
I'm figure out how to get you out of it
this looks like a clue mm I know right
y'all look a little sprout kick and
zombies lip and rank will I join for
some Cod maybe I'll join in the lobby
maybe not on stream here but in the
lobby with all you guys and just you
know join the team
cuz Ben and John Luke they usually hold
it down for the hosting the community
Fridays but I've definitely been
enjoying me some Cod I've actually been
enjoying the shooters free I've been on
this week because you know played the
cod beta I've also been capping some
footage on Call of Duty World War 2 for
another awesome video series that will
be having going up for GameSpot and then
now playing this has been fun too so
yeah it's like it's a strangely easy
transition to go from cause of this like
Percy said the controls are the same get
lost
got him zombies with accuracy that's a
scary thought true Lissa was a little
fungi no I can't get a break he kind of
reminds me has anybody ever seen that
movie cj7 see Jason yeah
sounds like I'm gone
RB RB RB all right my raithra recover a
little sprout almost didn't make it
his little heartbeat I felt in control
there vibrating - it was like oh really
I'm losing it but yeah this little guy
kinda reminds me a cv7 just his body
shape not in his head got him oh no no
one I gotta use that more like them area
names feel like I'm in Disneyland or so
this looks like toontown it's so cool
except I'm getting zapped yeah getting
that Mickey would never
Mickey is a man of happiness oppress why
they need to feel special time
protip thank you first down and out look
at that
although mushroom is a she that's thank
you oh really cool I can't even get out
of town
I'm ordered every time we intercept this
delivery yeah I know that the fungi we
talk to you to get to this town was a
girl name was Vivian oh right oh no you
need a breather y'all the shroom needs
to breathe here we go it's my special
loaded up yeah it is it's perfect time I
told you so many dings and tacos yes now
out of here wait oh these bats again
whoa intercepted okay
Oh No all right y'all plants I left
another bat zapper at the gas station
hurry okay I'm going
my Wraith run I can't even rape run
right now thanks for tuning in Jonas all
the way from Sweden we really appreciate
it and it's almost midnight over there
crazy was it Wow oh no I think the curse
got ya
Oh No thanks for joining in and have a
good night hope see you next time yeah
thanks for joining me
try not to dream about too many crazy
zombies okay time to get the bat yeah
they are chipping away at my help I
don't need y'all right now go away
please man
you that getting by no can I get a
second here okay I defend this this is
gonna be your last mission
so don't go I won't like that
practically suicide bomber usually yeah
20 more seconds Hugh
where they at were there here they come
it's very helpful so what's this I love
this run I mean use it nearly 20 corn
thank you
get there before the car
[Music]
you got to vanquish the concert hobbies
am i cool enough oh nice dodge yeah yeah
we don't got time for your antics on
booze oh we have a concert to interrupt
yeah
oh no you're slow if you guide us in if
you say that is
I'm here you're here time to ruin this
contract yes I love me a good evil laugh
oh no it's prompting a fight I know
thank loose them hopefully they start
you a full life noise I was I was just
trying to get here Wow give me he nods
down I'm stunned
apologies
you see this upgrade is actually really
it's him it's the boss it's stunning
them just trying to come back out of
here there we go there we go okay all
right
oh is it these little guns yeah I'm like
are those robots not on your side they
might not be actually okay okay okay
we're alive
don't forget your bubble oh yeah I did
happy place
have to destroy this set Oh No okay
great
yes yes okay now I can focus on
hopefully that laser beam that oh no oh
I think you should go out with a bang
I'll try it one seven that's gonna be it
okay fair enough yeah no no we're
getting like for those robots mess with
you they force you to go in there
okay sweet business you got this
Electric Slide is my new favorite zombie
says Lucy oh you stayed the same
weakness though that you got into it
yeah oh yeah he's a girl's gone you got
this bird here we go
no yep Crimea gave us an F for earlier
much needed
oh yeah you got it know that beam you
die yeah
oh you're so close
I wish I could play there is there you
go there you go there you go yeah I step
it outside
leave your area don't leave your oh oh
just kidding bro I like using the race
run for that laser I think it makes it
slide
I know me too
Richard we're fighting in the park now
we're not even in the DJ's own nice your
special boots break
the way we're talking to you
[Music]
do that I feel like he's lot that his
health right now what is it he got
really tired of me being over here he
haven't gone back to a little area is in
the roody-poo ow
and now we out like I reload
very small boy oh he's got
you
and health is like
there you go there you go decimal
Coneheads
selphie siphoning hose off of something
that's what I'm wondering - what's the
move
get it out got this family getting held
back from what sit alone
Oh what nice dodge you got that
[Music]
we doing a chat room for Persia let's go
oh man ok we're doing third-person
shooter things
boy
no no I got it disco boys small winning
sorry your health is good
I can't let him get another one of those
regenerating paintings
oh he didn't like that
might as well be blinking right now like
the old school games
honey years yeah they're the problem
oh there you are there you go not that
no no bad
Oh what is this it's really good while
now
oh no that Wraith run this is crazy so
many extras
[Music]
horse says the zombies are so weak they
are of another coming in numbers
and their stinky
I've heard number in the hurt
yeah haven't blinked in like three
minutes you got this
no way oh man he's moving fast now cuz
he's low special ready you got this
you're so cool he's down that was
awesome
we got the Hat that's all oh we were
fighting for his hats right that's how
you get the cool boy see that hat and a
Hawaiian shirt and take a fanny pack but
we got the Hat we got the Hat down hats
off bollocks man this game is just full
of tons full right in quite a morning
well you guys that's gonna wrap it up
for our stream today major sweetie
excuse me I'm doing my outro whoa whoa
miss thang but yes guys thank you guys
so much for tuning and thanks for
joining me and sprout sprout updated
thank you guys so much for tuning in
playing some plants vs. zombies with us
and I would actually comes out October
18th but if you get founders edition you
have access to it right yeah so if you
enjoyed what you saw go ahead and snag
that if you enjoyed watching us go ahead
and tune in every weekday at 11 a.m.
Pacific time right here on gamespot
thank you guys so much until next time
have a good one bye
you
you